PROFESSOR: OK, so
time for new subject.
Let's introduce the subject and
pose the questions that we're
going to try to answer.
And I feel that with
identical particles,
there's lots to think
about, and it makes it
into an interesting way
to conclude the course.
So identical particles.
So there is the issue
of defining what do you
mean by identical particles?
And then the issue
of treating them.
So when do we say that two
particles are identical?
We say two particles
are identical if all
their intrinsic properties--
like mass, spin, charge,
magnetic moment--
if all these things are the
same, these two particles--
we have particle
1 and particle 2--
are said to be identical.
For example, all electrons
And if you think about it,
well, what does that mean?
You can have an electron
moving with some velocity
and an electron standing here,
and they don't look identical.
They have different states.
Well, they're
identical in the sense
that-- what we said-- the
intrinsic properties are
the same.
Those two particle
have the same mass.
They have the same spin--
in principle.
They have the same charge.
Have the same magnetic moment.
Have all these same properties.
Now, they can be in
different states.
One electron can be
one momentum state,
an electron can be in
another momentum state.
One electron can be in
a spin state-- spin up.
This can mean spin down.
But what we would
mean is that if you
would put, by saying these
particles are identical,
we also mean they're
indistinguishable.
What that would mean
is that if one of you
gives me an electron with spin
up with some momentum state,
and--
yeah, let's say spin up
on some momentum state.
And another one of you gives me
another electron with same spin
up, same momentum state, and
I have those two electrons
and I play with
them for a minute
and I give them back
to you, you have
no way of telling you
got the same electron
or you got your
friend's electron.
There's no possible
experiment that can
tell which electron you got.
So when we have identical
particles like electrons--
elementary particles--
we understand
what it means to be identical.
Doesn't mean they're
in the same state.
It means that this is a
particle that all the properties
intrinsic of them are the same.
If you have a more
complicated particle,
you still can use the concept
of identical particles.
So, for example,
you have a proton.
A proton is a more
complicated particle.
It is made of quarks.
And if you have
two protons, they
are identical in
that same sense.
All the properties we
can give to the proton--
the spin state of
the proton, mass
of the proton, the dipole
moment of a proton,
the magnetic moment of a--
all those are the same.
If you prepare those
protons in identical states,
I cannot tell which is proton
1 and which is proton 2.
Then you have the neutrons.
Neutrons are the same thing.
The neutrons can be
in several states,
but two neutrons are
considered to be identical.
We can complicate matters more.
We can take hydrogen atoms.
Are hydrogen atoms
identical particles?
And in quantum mechanics,
we can think of them
as identical particles--
or identical atoms,
or identical molecules, or if
you write the wave function
for a hydrogen atom-- a new
kind of entity of particle--
we will use the axioms
of identical particles
even for the hydrogen atom.
But you could say, oh, no,
but they're not identical.
A hydrogen atom can be
in the ground state,
or it can be in
an excited state.
But that's the same as
saying this electrode is
going with little momentum,
and this is with high momentum.
These are states of
the hydrogen atom.
Just like an electron has
spin up and spin down,
hydrogen atom has this state,
that state, that state.
If you arrange them
in the same state,
you cannot tell
they are different.
So however clear these
comments can seem--
or confusing, perhaps--
things can be a little subtle.
In many ways, for
example, physicists
used to think of protons and
neutrons as the same particle.
Said what?
Well, that's the way
they thought about it.
It's a very nice thing.
If you're working
with energy scales,
the proton and neutron
mass difference
is not that big, first of all.
So at some scale for the
resolution of some experiments,
or physicists that didn't
have that many tools,
the proton and the neutron
were almost identical,
and people invented this
term called isospin.
And you might have heard of it.
It's a very famous symmetry
of the strong interactions.
In fact, for the
strong interactions,
you have a nucleus.
Whether you're a
proton or a neutron
doesn't make that
much difference.
So people used to think of
this thing as an isospin state.
Just the spin one half--
you have spin up, spin down.
Isospin means spin in some new
direction that is unimaginable.
But the isospin up
would be the proton,
the isospin down
would be the neutron.
And you will have a doublet.
So people used to think
of these two particles
as different states
of a nucleon,
and then they would say,
all nucleons are identical.
Why do you complain?
A proton is the
same as a neutron.
It's just a different
state of the isospin,
just like the spin electron
up or spin down is the same.
So the power of the
[? formalism ?] in quantum
mechanics is that it
allows you to treat
these things as
identical particles,
and this makes sense.
For you-- for your experiments--
these are identical things
that you can think of
different states of that.
You may as well
treat them that way.
So this is basically
what happens.
Now, so we define
the identical--
I didn't write anything here.
I'm going to get notes
out today on scattering,
and some of these
things as well.
So in classical mechanics--
classical mechanics-- identical
particles are distinguishable.
And that's the main thing.
How are they distinguishable?
Well, you have two
particles, and I can follow--
whenever they're moving, I can
say, OK, this is particle 1.
This is particle 2.
With quantum mechanics,
you can do the same thing
when they are really far
away-- those particles--
and they don't come
close together.
There's some sense in which
classical mechanics sometimes
applies, and that's
when they're far away.
Now, when the particles
in quantum mechanics
get close to each
other, then you
lose track which one is which.
They occupy the same position.
But in classical mechanics,
they are distinguishable,
because you can follow
their trajectories, which
is very nice.
You have an experiment.
You follow the particle,
say, oh, this is particle 1.
This is particle 2.
They're here together.
They're going around.
And they split, you
follow the trajectories
from the beginning to the end.
In quantum mechanics, there's no
such thing as the trajectories.
There's these waves.
The waves mix together.
They do things, then
they separate out,
and you just can't
tell what they do.
There's another technique that
we use in classical physics
that it's probably
also relevant.
We can tag the particles.
That means, if you're doing an
experiment with billiard balls
colliding, you could
take a little marker
and put a red dot on one
of them and a black dot
on the other one,
and that tagging
doesn't affect the collisions.
And you can tell, at the
end, where is the red ball,
and which is the black ball.
We do the same with
quantum mechanics.
There's no way anyone
has figured out
the tagging a particle
without changing drastically
the way interactions happen.
So it's a nice option
in classical physics,
but doesn't work in
quantum mechanics.
Even in classical physics, we
have something that survives.
If you have a Hamiltonian
for identical particles--
R2, P2-- that Hamiltonian is
symmetric under the exchange.
Whatever the
formula is, it's not
changed if you put
r2, p2 and r1, p1.
It's a symmetric thing.
The Hamiltonians
have that symmetry,
and there's no way to do this.
So let's get to the bottom--
the real problem with
identical particles
with quantum mechanics.
We cannot tag them.
Once these particles
get together,
you don't know what they did.
You do an experiment
of scattering
in the classical
mechanics, and you
put two particles coming
in, two detectors,
and you tag the particles
and you see what they do.
You do it in quantum
mechanics, and you
don't know if particle 1 did
that and particle 2 did this,
or if particle 1 did that
and particle 2 did that.
It's just not possible to tell.
They're very different.
So how do we deal with this?
Well, that's the subject
of what we're going to do,
but let's just conclude
today by stating the problem.
So the problem is that when we
had distinguishable particles
in quantum mechanics, we used
that tensor product to describe
a state.
So for distinguishable
particles, this thing which
all particles, say, 1 up to n,
we would use the tensor product
and write PSI i1 for
the particle one,
PSI i2 for the particle two,
PSI in for the particle n.
And this says particle one
is in the state PSI i1,
particle two is in the
state PSI i2, PSI in.
And these states are one of
many states, for example.
That's all good.
And this is for
distinguishable particles.
And that's all correct.
Now, suppose you have two
electrons, one up and one down.
If they are
indistinguishable, how
are we supposed to write the
state of the two electrons
or to spin one-half particles,
or maybe, in some cases,
maybe some other particles.
Am I supposed to write that the
first particle is in state up
and the second is in state down?
Or are I supposed to write
that the first particle is
in state down and the second
particle is in state up?
How do I describe the state
with this one or with this one?
They look equally plausible.
So if you were in charge of
inventing quantum mechanics,
one possibility that
it may occur to you
is that if the particles
are defined to be identical,
then those two states
should be identical.
They should be
indistinguishable, identical,
physically equivalent.
And this might be a good
hypothesis to consider.
Unfortunately,
that does not work.
You say, why not?
It seems so logical.
I cannot tell the difference
between these two.
Can I say that
they're equivalent?
Well, no.
If they would be equivalent,
you could form a state PSI alpha
beta, which is alpha
times the first plus
minus plus beta times
the second minus plus.
And I'm not going to write all
the subscripts nor the tensors
sometimes.
With alpha and beta having
this for normalization.
That's a normalized state.
Now, if all those
are equivalent,
if those two are
equivalent, all these
are equivalent for all
values in alpha and beta
because the superposition
of equivalence state
is an equivalent state.
But then let's ask for what is
the probability that we find
the two particles
in the state PSI 0,
which is plus along
the x direction times
plus along the x direction.
You know, whatever I do
whether this hypothesis there
that those two states are
equivalent is correct,
a state that is plus
and plus can only
be described one
way-- plus plus.
So I ask, what is
the probability
that this state PSI
alpha beta in the plus
along x and in the plus along x.
Now, you'll remember those
pluses are states like plus,
plus minus, 10 surplus
plus minus with a 1
over square root of 2.
And that becomes this.
So this is 1/2 of plus
plus plus plus minus,
plus minus plus
plus minus minus.
That's the state.
So what is the probability
that PSI alpha beta
is found in the state PSI 0?
It's this number.
Now, if you do the inner
product of these two vectors,
only the mixes ones
go with each other.
And this gives you 1/2 of
alpha plus beta squared.
And 1/2 of alpha
plus beta squared
is the inner product
of these two states.
And now you see that it depends
on the values of alpha and beta
because this is in fact 1/2 of
alpha squared plus beta squared
plus 2 real of alpha beta star.
And since alpha and
beta are normalized,
this is 1/2 plus real
of alpha beta star.
So this hypothesis that these
two states are equivalent
would mean that these states are
equivalent for all alpha beta
that are normalized.
And then you would have
that the probability
to be found in
PSI 0 would depend
on what the values of
alpha and beta you choose.
So it's a contradiction.
So we cannot solve the problem
of the degeneracy of identical
particles by declaring that
all the states are the same.
So we have to find a
different way to do it.
And that's what we
will do next time.